[Music]
you guys have probably seen my work on a
lot of famous celebrities but now you
can put a face to the name my name is
Elon and I work with Gabby Elon
[Music]
jewelry the piece that put us on the map
if you will was when Lil Uzi got a full
set of 10 and 10 diamond teeth they were
all hearts and arrows VBS it really
elevated our business from word to mouth
just whoever knows knows to these guys
are legit if these guys are shopping
with them then we can go there too the
first time I seen my dad do his work I
was probably like 8 years old I remember
he had a little like Workshop in the
basement he had a lot of molds I don't
know what the hell was going on I
thought he was like a full-on dentist
and then I found out he makes gold teeth
and I was like so excited as a kid I was
like I don't know what this is I started
working with my father when I was 16 we
moved to The damond District in 2018
that was the first time I got to like
work into a set with all the
customizations and all crazy ideas
behind it and all that stuff we rode the
waves until
now okay so we're going to start off
with this set this was done for Erica
Badu she got eight tops and six bottoms
this is inspired by an ancient Japanese
kugi art which is where they would take
ceramics that are broken and they would
weld it back together with gold wire so
it looks more artsy than
damaged her brand for her weed strain
that she came out with is called that
Badu and she actually gave me a little
baggie this is what inspired the whole
design for it so it matches but she
still wanted that whole kugi kind of
theme inside to make it look kind of old
and like rustic and it was perfect cuz
she wore it for the grand opening of her
weed strain event and this set cost her
about
13,000 we have J Balin set here from all
these this might be my favorite set this
was one of my original designs that I
drew out on my own I didn't have J Balin
as a client when I thought of this set
but when when I did have him as a client
I was like yo I have the perfect set for
you he came out with that color album
this was right after that and I was like
this is just for you I fell in love with
the set with all the colors with all the
intricate backstory to it like how the
stone cutting had to be done and it took
a lot of time and diligence but the
outcome was very worth it and I was very
pleased to see this these cost him about
[Music]
36,000 we did a set for Rihanna actually
she wanted to wear for her son's first
birthday where she announced his name
and and it was like a whole wuang theme
she got eight bottoms done and on the
top it just said dirt kind of like the
old dirty bastard iconic picture that he
has it says dirty on it so it it's kind
of cool to like relive that moment
through
Rihanna Kim K she got a few tests from
us she ordered a set that says Kim on it
but with individual diamonds that
actually spell out Kim on it not like
set as the shape but each Stone said k i
m like on its own so it was pretty cool
actually got that from a random
Instagram ad that I saw somebody post
posting diamonds on I saw he had a bunch
of letters so I was like hey by any
chance do you have K he's like is this
for the Kim I was like yeah I showed it
to her she loved it she loved the whole
idea so I tried to make it happen right
away and it it looked sick it came out
nice okay now we have push a t set this
set was dope he put on the cover of his
album I think he had it also for his
Tour on all the t-shirts and I actually
had a client send me one of the t-shirts
so it was it was pretty cool to see like
my own stuff on a t-shirt in
tour he just fell in love with the whole
Diamond idea when he saw F's and then he
saw F's wife's he's like I need that but
my teeth are a little messed up I got to
fix it around like you know however to
make it perfect so we just played around
like one Toth here one two there just to
make it a whole like mismatch kind of
pattern there's something about the
asymmetry that really just changes
everything and I love it I feel like it
has to tie in with the teeth how it look
so natural and not perfect symmetric
like soldiers it just brings out his
person ality his whole Spirit he's very
OG and he likes to stick to that this
set cost him
50,000 and these are for for reals these
were done back in 2006 with my father
doing the gold and Jacob and Co finish
all the diamond setting we have this set
also for for real this is done all in 22
karat yellow gold which is not so
popular to do cuz the gold is very soft
and it tends to bend fast it took a long
time this has almost 1,500 Stones inside
and it's just set perfectly forel paid a
little over 40,000 for this set LeBron
hit us up through a friend of mine
actually I don't really get Star Struck
but with LeBron I got a little star
struck I'm not going to lie he had his
whole management like send me his mold
and everything we contacted through
Instagram he requested his logo on it
like the little lion and then he just
said like I like gold I like purple I
said I got you no problem you're LeBron
this should be pretty simple and we did
the Nike check for him as a gift cuz I
was like I always wanted to do this and
he's the perfect guy for it and then
after that he said I love this set I
want to get a white gold one he we got a
set all hexagon cut on the bottom and
then the tops it was in between each
tooth we also got like baguettes that we
recut into hexagons and that one was
sick that was like a really flashy set
compared to this like calm like everyday
kind of
[Music]
one then we have a set we did for DJ
Mustard this is done in white gold all
VVS hearts and arrow diamonds and on the
bottom you have some fancy intense
yellows mixed in to give it a little
splash in the middle we drew a little
mustard bottle cuz he has a big mustard
chain and he wanted it to match he paid
I think 20,000 for the
set these are all for Marc Jacobs these
are two diamond teeth set in 22 karat
yellow gold hearts and arrow VBS best of
the best this was actually a funny story
he kept saying he wanted a chip tooth I
was like what do you mean you want a
chip tooth you don't have a chip tooth
his story was that he had a crush on
some kid when he was younger who had a
chip tooth and from then he always
thought it was like just the coolest
thing so I said okay we're going to cut
out a little piece we put black onx
inside so it looks like just something's
missing when you're standing from a
little far I think this set for Mark
jaob cost him about 24,000 alone and
then he paid about 8,000 for these and
then these two were another 2,000
each so we have all these sets these
were done for tokisha including this one
as well this is a set I don't even
remember what music video she did for
this but these are all done with
baguettes and then teardrop diamonds
here and one Ruby there she has a lot of
sets actually this is her iconic little
uh POA set if you will I think we all
know what this is this is a set she did
for mushrooms honestly I think this was
my favorite that she's done from all of
them it's just so beautiful so intricate
and it's like dainty but not too
boastful it's just like a piece of art
she just got these done actually she
shot a video with sexy red and it just
says Daddy all diamond and that's all
you see and it looks pretty dope this
one cost 13,000 this one cost her 4,000
the mushrooms are also 4,000 the eyes
were 5,000 poo was 2500 and these two
teeth were 2,000
each honestly I love my job I love what
I do I I love waking up every day to be
able to make something so unique so
intricate and work with the best
possible clientele that I can find I
know a lot of people that don't like to
go to work I wake up every day and I'm
like wow I can't wait to go to the
office it's just everything I could ask
for anymore thanks GQ this is on the
rocks and I'm going to see you guys back
at the
office